just over a year ago I made a video
about the cycling mechanic that video
featured a brief history of the mechanic
and Associated decks as well as a
discussion of why I dislike a particular
Commander printed for the mechanic a few
years ago that video also features a
brief description of my own cycling deck
a Sherm deck built around the card
astral slide that deck has endured more
so than basically any other I've built
it's the only deck built before I
started making YouTube videos that both
still gets played regularly and also
hasn't changed
dramatically however the process of
building it was also way different than
that of the other decks I've built my
decks broadly tend to be less Synergy
focused and more play pattern focused
with deck Dynamics being unusual but the
cards themselves being often somewhat
more generic budget Staples rather than
coming from a particular Synergy package
this deck was a massive exception to
that every card was meticulously chosen
to perform hypers specific roles and
mesh with as many other cards as
possible for that reason this deck ended
up being easily my most difficult deck
to build thrusting me well outside my
normal comfort zone of deck building I
actually left the deck unchanged for
about a year starting in mid toate 2023
purely because it was functioning okay
and I was terrified that any changes I
half-hazard made would lead to the deck
falling apart its mysterious Special
Sauce getting tainted however late last
year I deed decided that it was finally
time to update the deck both adding
newly printed cards and smoothing out a
handful of longtime issues and with the
success I've enjoyed with the deck since
then I figured I should give a full
overview of how I built the deck what
makes it work and what it says about how
we as EDH players build decks to start
with let's talk about the origins of the
deck the starting point for building it
was browsing a card gallery of onslaught
cards and having a couple particular
cards stand out to me one of these was
astral slide a three Mana white
enchantment that flickers a creature
whenever a card is cycled and this
offers an effective way to reuse etbs
and temporarily remove opposing
creatures the other card was oversold
Cemetery a two Mana black enchantment
that returns a creature from his
controller's graveyard to their hand on
each of their upkeeps as long as there
are four or more creatures in that
graveyard this effect can act as a
recursion engine enabled by cycling and
can also be used to Simply keep up
astral slide fodder from there I decided
that I also wanted blue since that's a
color that shares a lot of synergy
elements with what I was building and
which also gives access to a nice range
of commanders after a brief Commander
hunt I ended up settling on shirom as an
esper Commander with an impactful
graveyard oriented ETB these three cards
alone already paint a decently clear
picture of the sort of deck I was going
to be building an ETB centered cycling
Deck with artifact and graveyard sub
themes some key enchantments and enough
creatures to get oversold Cemetery
online if that sounds specific it's
because it is immediately a handful of
challenges presented themselves
different conditions that my deck would
need to fulfill in order to be even
remotely functional for one the deck
needs a lot of cycling cards for
purposes of reliable astral slide
triggers I ended up deciding that a high
30s count was about right and have stuck
with around that number through various
iterations of the deck secondly a
reasonably High creature count for
oversold Cemetery at least 30 thirdly a
way to find key cards the deck relies on
astral slide for its game plan and there
are only three cards that perform the
function of Astral slide so some tutors
to find them will be very helpful
finally the deck needs ways to get cards
in its graveyard with draw and discard
effects seeming most appropriate I found
that seven was basically as low as I
could go for these okay so this is
immediately placing a lot of
requirements on the deck with the high
30s count of cycling cards being perhaps
the most rigorous even if we consider
the 14 available cycling lands in esper
colors and run all of them which I do
that still means that we're looking at
less than 40 available slots for
non-land non- cycling cards which means
that cards need to perform multiple
roles or else be utterly fantastic at
their main job for ETB creatures the
majes were a great starting point three
Mana 2u Wizards that tutor for an
artifact of a specific Mana cost and
sphinx Summoner was a similarly sweet
inclusion tribute Mage finds fluctuator
which is a key card for the deck since
it gives great Mana savings on cycling
back-to-back cards but aside from that
these cards mostly find secondary cards
for the deck so what about tutors to
find the deck's key enchantments Ash
sliden Co since I was already in esper
colors a Natural Choice was Zur a
creature who can tutor out lowcost
enchantments whenever he attacks
conveniently he's also a wizard which
brings me to a key piece of this deck
wizard cycling there are two different
wizard cycling cards in existence which
end up being solidly costed instant
speed tutors that also count as a cycle
for astral side purposes as an added
bonus one of these is a flash creature
which is grabbable with the newly
printed mdfc water logged teachings I
got a chance to do this a couple weeks
back and there's nothing like the rush
of tutoring to find a tutor to find a
tutor to find an astral slide now this
may seem a bit deranged and yeah it kind
of is but it also points to a key facet
of this deck its status as a toolbox
deck this phrase means that the deck has
a network of conditional tutors that can
each find a certain selection of cards
that the deck might need in various
situations for example the deck's wizard
cycling cards can find four tutors as
well as an excellent recursion card and
three cards for purposes of countering
opposing spells and abilities worth
pointing out is that all of these work
with astral slide in some way gaining
additional value off of slide or finding
slide or triggering slide delving deeper
into the toolbox the most useful of the
three artifact Mages treasure Mage can
find life gain a finisher multiple types
of removal and a couple value sources
and the fact that it's repeatable with
astral slide is a big deal since it lets
me load up on topend threats that I can
discard and then shirom back out sphin
Summoner can find most of the stuff that
treasure Mage can since most of them are
artifact creatures and it can also find
a board wipe and an angsty bird in
addition to the selection of conditional
tutors there's also a couple cards from
one of my favorite mechanics in all of
magic transmute these are cards that
allow their controller to pay three mana
and discard them to tutor for a card of
the same Mana cost I originally had the
three Mana enchantment tutor idilic
tutor in this deck but honestly a three
Mana transmute card does a similar job
of giving me access to key enchantments
and also gives me access to other useful
things like the recursion of tesi the
graveyard hate of bogert trowler the
graveyard feeding of thirst for
knowledge and so on as well as being a
very funny counter spell on top of it
all the cumulative effect of all of
these individual highly conditional
tutors is striking I have six other
cards that can lead me to one of my
three key astral slide enchantments or
one of my topend artifact creatures and
I have five other cards that can lead me
to fluctuator or oversold Cemetery I
also have a lot of cards that can be
grabbed by just one or two tutors
meaning that this deck ends up being a
massive web of different tutors which
can each prompt me with interesting
decisions to make this quantity of
tutors might sound objectionable to some
but well hear me out I'll get back to
that objection with the key cards and an
overview of the toolbox out of the way
let's get to how this deck plays in
practice early turns are spent sculpting
a hand ramping and beginning to assemble
value engines there are a lot of cards
that can be played out early and then
astral slid later to reuse the etbs the
artifact Mages my sad robots my angsty
bird and so on this early game can also
be a time to feed the graveyard being
able to shom out a massive artifact on
turn five or six can offer a nice Tempo
swing that forces my opponents onto the
back foot and gives me room to develop
my advantage I talk about this deck in
terms of tempo and Advantage because
this deck is a control deck through and
through you might not be able to tell
this by looking at the deck it's running
a relatively High creature count of 35
and its Commander is a generic artifact
recursion card from allara block its
quantity of counter spells while
probably higher than average in raw
terms is nothing crazy and consists
mostly of spells which can also either
be transmuted or cycled it's also not
running a single conventional board wipe
sure there's an incomplete wipe a sleep
effect a multi creature edict and a
couple things that reduce power and
toughness based on the amount of Mana
put in but nothing that says destroy all
anything so what makes this a control
deck fundamentally it comes down to this
deck's play pattern highlighting my
deck's astral slide Targets in archade
immediately gives an indication of this
a big part of this deck's game plan is
repeating value generation and removal
and that repeated removal can be some
heavy duty hate over the course of
multiple turn Cycles more broadly at any
given moment in a game this deck will be
balancing three different goals stay
alive suppress opponents and build value
Staying Alive means keeping my life
total up and preventing opponents from
winning suppressing opponents means
taking actions that worsen my opponent's
position in the game and building value
means doing things that improve my
position in the game the desirability of
working toward these different goals
runs from right to left I love to build
up my own value I'm happy enough to take
actions that slow down my opponents and
make them less of a threat and I don't
really like needing to spend time and
resources staying alive but that one's
pretty unnegotiable if I want to keep
having a shot at winning a game my
chances of winning go up and up the more
I get to focus on these right two my
ideal game is one where all of my energy
can go into building up my own engine of
ETB creatures and cycling spells as well
as neutralizing opposing engines and
threats early in their lifespan so
that's the biggest feature of this deck
balancing these different elements early
turns are spent building resources
getting blockers on board and getting
ready to answer anything my opponents
are doing that is an existential threat
to my position in the game since this is
a toolbox deck every suppression tool
that I don't need to grab means a piece
of value or ramp instead and once I have
astral slide and play there will often
be choices between flickering creatures
that are suppressive or defensive in
some way and flickering ones that boost
my game plan as a result threat
evaluation is key to keeping opponents
in check without losing too much
momentum the deck can make more daring
early plays but these often come at the
cost of long-term value so it's
important to weigh the pros and cons and
to have have follow-up plays in mind one
natural question might be well what do I
mean by follow-up how does this deck win
well as with most control decks this
deck is trying to reach a state of
stability where it has a lot of agency
over the state of the game this state
will look different depending on the
game because different tools will be
required to keep different opposing
decks in check here are a handful of
things that might be true in the endgame
scenario though in no particular order
one a lot of Mana either through land
counts bu up by flickered robots or
Power Stone tokens that can pay for
cycling costs two a healthy hand of
cards especially one that includes
multiple cycling cards as well as things
like counter spells and recursion pieces
Nimble obstructionist is especially nice
as it deals with a lot of pesky
abilities that most control decks don't
have a way to handle three utility
permanence that keep the deck chugging
along such as engines that build value
turn overt turn and permanence that can
disrupt opposing attempts to regain
footing four a high life total that puts
me out of range of dying to any number
of of common threats as well as enough
blockers to handle any sudden attacks
once enough of these conditions are met
winning the game from there is usually
straightforward a key type of creature
for this deck is medium to large Flyers
a type which includes the commander and
these constitute a decent threat to life
Turtles given enough time as long as I'm
able to give them that time they'll
usually win me the game however there
will be some games where an opponent
will get a very high life total or
alternatively will be in a highly
threatening position with a normal life
total so I run a couple finisher cards
as well one I alluded to earlier maest
Sphinx is a fantastic card giving me a
way to rapidly burst down a problem
player this can be extremely sudden for
my opponents on the second main phase
before my turn I can play a draw discard
effect to discard Magister Sphinx and
then cycle something to flicker Shum and
bring back Magister Sphinx turning an
opponent's life total to 10 then on my
turn I can cycle a couple more things to
clear out any flying blockers before
one-shotting the problem opponent who
could have been at any life total a
single turn earlier the other finisher I
run is Herold of the Forgotten this can
bring back any of my 14 cycling
creatures in my graveyard and
importantly it can also bring back any
of my 14 cycling lands this is great
it's usually a burst of creatures to
contest the board but also a burst of
ramp to fuel my later turns this second
part is so big for the deck because the
creatures don't even need to be
impactful even if it's just some extra
blockers it also gives me a burst of
resources fueling both my staying alive
and building value goals so that's
basically the deck it's a highly
flexible cycling based control Deck with
graveyard artifact and wizard packages
woven throughout there are a lot of more
common play patterns such as flickering
a key creature like Angel of the ruins
or treasure Mage with astral slide but
also a lot of more Niche play patterns
for example if I have a lot of mana and
opposing value is mostly based around
creatures being untapped monstrosity of
the lake can be flickered every turn to
keep opposing stuff permanent Ely slept
this isn't a common play but the fact
that monstrosity has Island cycling
makes it a low investment card to
include in the deck another Niche play
is using oversold cemetery and Nimble
obstructionist as a stifle engine which
can keep a key opposing effect that
triggers once a turn suppressed a couple
other interesting plays tesi can turn
mdfc and cycling lands to hand to be
used later and currency converter can
protect key artifacts from sorcery speed
graveyard hate for a somewhat Saucier
play perplex can be followed up with
another counter spell to bait an
opponent into discarding their hand for
three Mana in exchange for absolutely no
benefit I just keep on discovering new
ways to play this deck and that fact
also provides a great Advantage when it
comes to resiliency no matter what my
opponents remove or how my opponent slow
me down I have a way to play around it
and keep building advantage in some way
or other the recursion Suite of this
deck is quite robust and this is also a
rare deck that actually has good access
to stifle effects to deal with graveyard
hate even without it graveyard the deck
can still build value around its astral
slide effects since the deck's high
density of cycling cards means that all
that's needed to have a value engine is
an astral slide style enchantment and an
ETB creature at least one of these two
things graveyard based value building
and astral slide based value building is
usually necessary to keep up but those
two things can take a countless number
of different forms and there are lots of
smaller packages riddled throughout the
deck that can pose decent threats all on
their own the fact that there are so
many different themes that are so
interconnected in the deck means that
pivots are much easier than they would
be in most other decks the fact that my
cord card is astral slide means that I
have a way to resist creature board
wipes and a way to break parody on
creature-based Stacks effects on hand
almost always the fact that most of my
game actions are abilities rather than
spells also insulates me against a lot
of conventional hate for fiddly control
decks the fact that my deck runs lots of
unique effects and conditional tutors
means that I can simply avoid tutoring
for a specific effect if there's
currently hate for it lurking around the
fact that the deck deres its consistency
from filtering and tutors allows Sheron
to play a more supporting role to Simply
Be cast for a burst of value before
hanging around as a beater until some
astral slide Shenanigans are ready to
happen the wide array of different play
paths and effects in this deck is
equally beneficial in making this deck
resilient to hate and in making this
deck interesting to play tutors though I
did say I'd get back to them and now is
as good a time as any to address the
many tutoring crimes of this deck tutors
are a subject of contention within the
Casual EDH Community with many players
seeing them as a sweaty cedh tool that
goes against the spirit of the format
other players simply see them as boring
making decks more streamlined and
formulaic rather than offering the wide
diversity of plays that EDH should be
about I don't think anybody is
necessarily wrong for their feelings
about this tutors can be a formulaic
tool for the sweat Lords of the world
anybody who has played against a natural
ordered crater hoof or a demonic tutored
infinite combo can attest to this tutors
can feel Bland and deflating just an
extra copy of a powerful game-ending
spell it might be interesting to
interrogate why they're more bland and
deflating than that power card simply
being drawn and played my hunch is that
it comes down to Lucky top decks simply
being accepted as a part of the game but
still these source of plays don't make
people feel good and I don't think
they're wrong for that I myself don't
really play unconditional tutors tutors
that can find any card in a player's
library because I don't find them very
interesting at the same time the taring
of tutors as a universal boring tool is
a bit wrongheaded tutors can find the
easy win but they can also find all
sorts of things such as a centerpiece
engine that all sorts of other cards can
build off of in cool and textured ways I
hear people say that tutoring up a card
every game having a secret Commander if
you will goes against the spirit of EDH
but if having easy access to a card
playing it every game and coordinating
other cards to work nicely with it goes
against the spirit of EDH then I really
have no choice but to conclude that EDH
goes against the spirit of EDH pack it
up folks the formont was doomed from the
start no tutors are not inherently
boring and the things that make them
boring or not boring are what you do
with them same as any other type of card
in my case conditional tutors actively
make my deck more interesting tutors
allow me to run a greater variety of
cards cards that interact in cool and
complex ways and it allows this because
tutors improve my ability to find
different sorts of cards from within my
deck there are some cards that just
aren't great without at least some
support from my core cards and without
tutors for those core cards those
wouldn't be good enough there are other
types of cards that perform a specific
role but who can't fill this role fully
enough without tutors to find them
absent ways to find my key cards I'd be
forced to run more generic cards cards
that are good by themselves and that fit
into a smaller number of synergy roles
rather than the rich tapestry of synergy
I'm able to fit into my deck through the
power of tutors I'm able to run very
little generic ramp generic draw generic
removal and so on my card choices get to
be more interesting and more specific to
my deck because I have a suite of
conditional tutors to help me put things
together and that makes my deck more
interesting as with most decks my game
plan builds off of a few Central node
cards but there's a ton of diversity in
what things actually end up looking like
because of how Niche and creative my
card choices were able to be this isn't
to say that tutors inherent make a deck
interesting there are decks I find less
interesting that run a lot of tutors and
four of my six current Decks that I play
regularly run none at all and I like to
think that those decks aren't too boring
but having or not having tutors will
impact the options that a deck can go
with and going tutor lless will often
mean sacrificing either power or
specificity you'll end up with a deck
that's simpler and runs more generic
cards as the non- tutoring four of my
six decks 2 to some extent or you'll end
up with a deck that doesn't place
smoothly and might not be able to keep
up and make its cool plays in a lot of
games as I said at the start of this
video this was a deck outside my normal
comfort zone of deck building both for
the process of originally building it
and for the process of updating it there
are a lot of potential reasons for this
but the biggest one is that this deck
pushes beyond the bounds of the levels
of synergy that I and most other EDH
players are used to using running a
bunch of different Synergy packages in
the same deck can be tricky and doing it
elegantly requires putting an intense
degree of focus on the points of
connectivity and places where different
archetypes overlap as a result building
this deck was basically a peac meal
project of adding different packages and
cards that fit the rigorous requirements
of the deck I started with the two key
cards and added cherum once I decided on
my color identity and that I wanted a
commander with an ETB the Mages were
added because they were artifact Synergy
cards that were also etbs and once I
found wizard cycling as a way to connect
cycling to these Wizards I was able to
Loop in Zur as a tutorable way to find
my key enchantments teshi was pulled
into this wizard cycling package as well
as a way to recur my two key card types
and Hall of Helio's generosity and Guy
reach sanitarium were added as landbased
ways to recur and loot respectively once
it was clear that land cycling had me
covered for color fixing teres AR's
Devastation made it in as a lovely ramp
board wipe pairing in place of a hard
wipe and a few different mdfc ended up
being a great way to compress my slots
even further to squeeze just that little
extra bit of of utility out of
everything as well as working well with
tesi even late in the process I'm still
finding new ways to tighten up synergies
just that extra little bit erti
resurrected was a recent addition to
this deck as a card that counter spells
and removes creatures as an ETB and he's
a wizard on top of it all I still don't
know if I've reached the most optimized
and cohesive possible version of this
deck there are just so many cards that
could possibly work in the deck
depending on matchups I find myself in
more than I have time to test all of I
also don't know if I found the perfect
blend of interaction yet recent play
testing has had the board wipes feeling
a bit underrepresented and soft counter
loocks on non- creature spells feeling
over represented but I have no idea if
that pattern will hold in the long term
what you can take away from this is that
building a hyperconnected Synergy
machine like this is a slow creeping
iterative process the lower hanging
fruits can be found from a scryfall
search in an afternoon tossing all of
the best cards with a particular word or
phrase into a deck but if you're trying
to weave together a bunch of different
things under tight constraints it will
be more of a process the most important
part of this process is finding nodes to
build off of that pull different
elements together and then including
only cards that perform multiple roles
or that perform their primary role
fantastically well in this deck that
meant viciously scrutinizing any card
that wasn't an artifact with a fetchable
Mana value a cycling card a key
enchantment a wizard or an ETB creature
what survived that scrutiny not many
cards we've got some looters some
multimodal tutors and a small handful of
best-in-class cards in a deck like this
it's also important to be able to weed
out cards that might share a Synergy
pillar but which aren't actually good
enough as far as cycling synergies go
curator of mysteries isn't actually
worth playing as a creature basically
ever Joe Grant isn't great for the same
reason Drake Haven isn't great outside
of a go wide creature deck and abandoned
sarcophagus is an actively Bad Card
likewise it might be tempting to load up
on a bunch of nifty wizard Synergy cards
but these are all that great either with
the numbers of wizards this deck is
running and forcing in a wizard count
high enough to make them good would tank
other parts of the deck building an
elaborate and meticulous Synergy machine
requires restraint above all else you
need to be able to resist the urge to
throw cards in just because of a single
idealized situation you constructed in
your brain what do cards look like in
the less ideal half of situations you'll
be finding them in that's always an
important thought to cycle through and
one that'll save you a lot of wasted
time testing cards that realistically
never had a chance of being a permanent
fixture of a deck the other thing you
can take away from my Endeavor here is
that it's worth it to build a deck
that's difficult to build if the process
I described in the last few minutes
sounded hard that's because it was
building a deck like this is a challenge
but that's also what makes it such a
gratifying exercise seeing the deck
actually work out after I put hours into
tuning it is satisfying and figuring out
new ways I can smooth over some rough
edges in it is also satisfying the the
fact that I still have a large maybe
board in paper and a mental list of
pivots I could try for solving various
problems is exciting and forcing myself
to engage with a deck like this has
undoubtedly made me a stronger deck
builder this interlocking Synergy
machine type of deck is the one I
personally find hardest to build but
your difficult to build deck style might
be different whatever it is though you
should take a crack at it it's difficult
to fight back against a deck building
weakness but the resulting decks can be
really
cool that pretty well sums up the video
however I have an announcement it's a
birthday party for our Discord server
okay what I mean to say is that I'm
running another deck building challenge
that challenge goes as follows build a
deck using one of the following choose a
background commanders Ellen harb's Busy
Body hson Emerald AR Druid Amber gal
allora Mary thief and viconia Dr
apostate they can be paired with any
background that appeals to you a top
deck for each Commander will be selected
and highlighted in a future video and
judging criteria will be as last time
creativity cohesion and likelihood to
produce Dynamic gameplay and this time
there's a prize the creator of each of
the top decks will receive a haunted one
alter hand painted by my friend Mecha
caten who did the art for my channel
banner and profile picture if that
sounds up your alley you can find out
more info about the challenge in my
Discord server and you'll want to submit
a deck by noon PST on Tuesday the
21st as always I want to thank my
patrons for supporting what I do here
allowing me to make High effort videos
like this one without needing to worry
too much about how they'll Faire in the
algorithm submissions for this month's
Deck review will run until the end of
tomorrow so if you want a chance at
getting your deck reviewed by me you can
check that out if you want more of me
and don't want to pay money I was on an
episode of the magic mirror podcast that
should be releasing around the same time
as this video and there I go further
into my feelings about tutors along with
my two co-hosts a link to that is in the
description all right bye now